we finished the last video in the year
bce
where the year began with the parthian
invasion of syria and the eastern
provinces of the roman republic and
really is an empire the roman republic
or the roman empire but mark anthony who
was in control of the east of the empire
he wasn't able to deal with it
immediately because he goes to
brundicium in order to take his wife's
side on a civil war between her and
octavian now his wife dies and he makes
good with octavian in fact so good with
octavian he marries octavian's sister
octavia and they decide all right let's
let's continue to be friends here and
they divide the the roman empire the
roman republic whatever you want to call
it between them where mark anthony
keeps control of the east
you now have octavian with control over
the west and they gave lepidus who's
always a bit of the third wheel here
they gave him
some of the southern provinces right
over there
now it seems like all is good but as
we've already talked about the the
tension between antony and octavian is
there it was there from the beginning
and in this video we're going to see
that it gets a lot a lot worse
so mark anthony goes
back to
the east where he starts planning his
invasion of parthia not only does he
want to take back the territory that
they took in 40 bce but he actually
wants to avenge them for crassus's death
in 53 bce julius caesar had been planted
planning an invasion of persia and you
have to remember
after alexander the great all of these
western rulers especially the romans
they all had their sights on persia they
said hey maybe i can be just like
alexander the great and take over the
persians so mark anthony is planning his
invasion of persia but he doesn't get
the troops that he wants from octavian
and so that starts to build the tensions
even further but he goes to his his
lover cleopatra who is the richest woman
in the world the pharaoh of egypt and
says hey can you give me some egyptian
troops
and so he plans an invasion of of
parthian parthian persia with a combined
roman and egyptian troops
now unfortunately that is a failed
invasion as they try to make their way
in they get pretty far but they weren't
able to come to protect their supply
lines carefully and so the parthians are
able to the parthians are able to attack
them
attack their supply lines and while they
do the king of armenia just kind of
doesn't really do anything about it and
so mark anthony is forced to retreat and
so you can imagine he's not too happy
about this the parthians in 40 bce
were able to take all of this territory
and 36 bce
we're so now we are
right
now we are
right over here in 36 bce we have a
failed i guess your revenge invasion of
the parthians he's betrayed by the
armenian king now the other thing that's
happening is that lepidus is now out of
the triumvirate he tries to do a little
bit of a land grab after after him and
octavian go after another uh i guess you
say governor in sicily but when they're
successful when lepidus tries to take
control of sicily octavian says no no no
no not only can you not do that but
you're now out of you're now out of the
triumvirate so 36 bce is a situation
where octavian continues to try to
consolidate his power in the west
lepidus is now out
and mark antony faces another i guess
you say embarrassment against the
parthians
so then we get to 33 bce
so let's see this is 33 bce right over
here on this map and finally he's able
to muster up enough of a force to
take
not revenge on the parthians but to take
some of the territory but in particular
to take revenge on the armenian king
and so mark anthony you know it's his
first win after a while tries to make a
lot of this and so when he goes
he goes back to alexandria where of
course his lover cleopatra reigns
and there he has this big celebration to
say hey look i went and was able to take
out the king of armenia now this this
celebration
it rubs the romans in the in the wrong
way on a whole bunch of dimensions one
they never really like cleopatra they
view her as a as a foreign queen they
didn't like her when she was
the julius caesar's lover they
definitely don't like her when she's
mark anthony's lover
and they're kind of peeved that he
decides to go to alexandria and do this
ceremonial victory party that typically
only happened in rome it looks like this
guy doesn't really even view himself as
roman anymore he likes to go back to
alexandria and the real salt that he
rubbed especially in octavian's wounds
was a speech he gave which will later be
known as the donations of alexandria so
what he starts doing is putting his
children especially the children that he
has with cleopatra as
the rulers of a lot of the eastern
provinces but the worst thing that he
does is in that speech in the donations
of alexandria
this is in 33 bce right over here he
declares that cleopatra's son that was
apparently the son of julius caesar
cesareon that he is the rightful heir to
julius caesar now octavian does not like
this he says hey i'm the adopted son i'm
the right flair i don't like the
cesarean guy
and so for the next few years and 33 and
32 bcs or in this period on that
timeline where this or in this period on
this timeline tensions start to get a
lot lot lot worse between octavian and
mark anthony they are publicly accusing
each other
of not even being legitimate uh people
with legitimate authority they are
really starting to question each other
they're really starting to go at each
other and it all culminates in
in 31 bce
it all culminates in 31 bce so this is
where we are right over here with the
naval battle at actium
and for the most part and mark anti and
cleopatra are both there and they're on
their heels they're surrounded by the
forces of octavian and the best that
they can hope for is just an escape
and
anthony and cleopatra are able to escape
and it's very clear from that battle
that they really only cared about saving
their own hides and their own wealth
and they left the most of their navy
they they they returned with only 60
boats to alexandria but they leave most
of their navy to kind of have to deal
with the forces of octavian so they were
already on the heels they have this
escape in 31 bce most many historians
will call the battle of actium and this
is a depiction of the naval battle at
actium right over here as the end
after this it was there was no chance
really for cleopatra and mark antony in
any way to rival octavian that octavian
was now the the real soul power and what
is evolving from a roman republic to a
roman empire
but anti and cleopatra maybe they didn't
realize it as much they go back to
alexandria and continue
to plot seeing how they can get back at
octavian so octavian doesn't want much
of this so he decides to go attack them
in alexandria in 30 bce
and anthony tries to make a lack stand
against octavian but his military his
soldiers really aren't in the mood to
fight so he goes back to the palace he
looks for cleopatra cleopatra gets one
of her servants to tell mark anthony
because he has no mood to see him
because who knows he's he's raving mad
he might want to kill her kill him who
knows what he might want to do
cleopatra had her servant tell mark
anthony
that cleopatra was dead and so mark
antony he's already down his his
soldiers have deserted him there's no
way for him to take on octavian he's
essentially lost and now cleopatra his
lover is apparently dead he stabs
himself repeatedly in the stomach now
cleopatra finds out about this and then
she has mark anthony brought to him he
doesn't die immediately stabbing
yourself in the stomach is a way of
having a very slow and painful death
and while and he dies essentially in her
arms and then cleopatra is taken then by
the forces of octavian but then she too
decides that she wants to commit suicide
or at least that's what most accounts
say and the most uh common account is
that she gets a snake
smuggled into her rooms a poisonous
snake
that she taunts and gets to bite her
which allows her to die so both
cleopatra and mark anthony die in 30 bce
and octavia now the really the main
power he kills caesarean who was
cleopatra's son with julius caesar as
the only possible rival and so here we
are on 30 bce octavian is victorious and
then he goes back to rome and continues
to consolidate his power until we get to
27 bce which is often marked as the
beginning of the roman empire
when octavian was given the name
augustus which means illustrious one and
from then on he will continue to reign
with more and more and more power that
he continues to consolidate for many
many many many more decades